good morning everyone and Millennials
included we saw a Facebook comment that
looked hilarious that you're proud to be
in a millennial where at least you know
you're free which is very pertinent and
very true very I am here with Kristen
McNamara friend of scenes pop culture
expert Wow huge sakes writer girl thank
you thank you for joining us I'm so
excited I'm so excited it's just gonna
be girls hanging out having like just
two pop culture experts at shooting the
[ __ ] and also just two friends yeah son
back about skin we met at camp the same
camp where camp toast will be taking
place so if you have any sort of
logistical questions about the campsite
you know how the showers work sinds your
girl - I'm your girl anything you got to
ask wait - speaking of camper one second
do you know - I was thinking about this
morning and cracking up when we all sang
in the talent show who did the crime oh
my god wait what did you Indian fire
towns yes and me and Claudia sang who
says by Selena Gomez just uplift all the
campers it was a beautiful moment this
is such a simpler time when Selena Gomez
was singing one of the most underrated
song who says it's yeah it's a winner
for sure
I feel pretty of songs it is although
it's better even though spin told me
that she watched I feel pretty last
night for the first time and she did not
like it which is shocking I mean I was
telling Jackie I went into it hey I
don't love Amy Schumer but I wanted to
give the movie a chance because I liked
her previous movies but ya know I didn't
laugh once I hated everything about it
pretty I liked the message but I'm so
crazy I didn't laugh sorry but I guess
if you have to watch I get to our movie
with a character that you don't like
you're not gonna like the movie exactly
there's not there's no chance like if I
had to watch a two-hour movie with Lena
Dunham starring I there's no chance I'm
gonna like the movie there's no chance
anyone's don't like that sorry we got
also I finally finished shutter island'
last night I wish I'm excited for
Claudia to come back on Monday so we
could talk about it haven't you seen it
I've seen it but not a long time but I
remember that it's mind it's a mind
twisted a mind twister and I actually
enjoyed it because I don't like horror
films and while I was watching it I was
like wow this is so not my kind of movie
this is way too dark for me Holocaust
vibes can't and chant but then what
actually winds up happening which I'm
obviously not gonna spoil is a way more
uh palatable thing and I don't remember
what happened what you thought was
happening just you had toilet but I'll
say if you want to meet me for a second
that's fine I'll say it's all about
perspective oh okay
yes I remember okay you can unmute me
anyways we have as always a fabulous
story fabulous show for you guys today
very well rounded story very plus it's
Friday so we're just in high spirits Oh
TGIF I'm seeing Taylor Swift tonight so
I mean especially high spirit I see were
supposed to go together but now I'm
going on Sunday still good she bailed
but deep ok when when a concert is in
town for like three nights which and I
do you think it's the best show grab
this
okay I think the first one that was
listed is the best one because those are
the real fans that were waiting to get
the tickets and then you have they add a
second show and they add a third show so
I don't know which one was the first one
listed if I think it might be what did
they were all listed at the same time
okay because I remember I saw Drake at
Madison Square Garden I think he did
like three nights three or four nights
there and he was saying like this is the
best crowd that we've had in New York
yet and I was like you definitely said
they said every million crowds and I
want to know it in your heart of hearts
who was the best New York crowd oh
that's a great question maybe it's the
last night especially when it's a good
City because it's like this is the
farewell in New York obviously is one of
the best cities that she's going to so
maybe you're going to the right show and
I'm going to the wrong show I don't know
you have to let me know what she says
that the crowd and I like know what she
says that like and she's gonna talk
about your crowd be like night one crowd
was [ __ ] you're right I'm gonna never
say that she would never actually this
is a great segue into our first story
because it does involved miss Swift
herself who's ready to hear the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I am I am I'm
ready for some morning toast except not
gonna happen cuz I haven't had a carb in
two weeks and I'm sock to his life that
acting back on it slow and steady I
don't know I don't know man how do you
feel though lethargic tired hungry sad
so you know Kido you get that Kido
sickness when you first start touching
food yes and every time I restart Atkins
which is all the time because I'm always
going off of it you go through the
induction flu where literally you feel
sick and just like lethargic I mean you
know it's the inductions loose so you
just have to power through and drink
some electrolytes but it is very much a
thing yeah I believe it that's why you
shouldn't restart it so many times cuz
the induction flu is terrible oh that
like just headaches
I'm never gonna but now I'm in a good
place now I'm like that's I don't have
cravings really and it's decent it's
just there's not many that many things I
can eat yeah it's annoying I started
eating kosher beef jerky which is kind
of fun that scares me
no I know beef jerky is so scary but
it's so scary why is it quite good I
don't know it's just like dried meat and
but how come it doesn't have to be
refrigerated cuz it has like so much
sodium I think like oh you know it's
good for what in a wartime situation I
think Oh slim jims okay first stop
Taylor Swift James Corden Jennifer
Hudson haven't been announced as the
cast of cats Jennifer Hudson Taylor
Swift James Corden Ian McKellen have
been cast in working titles upcoming
movie version of Andrew Lloyd Webber's
smash musical Cats
Tom who bird the oscar-winning director
of The King's Speech will direct cats
which is set to begin shooting in
Britain in November the screenplay by
Lee Hall who did Billy Elliot is based
on Lloyd Webber's musical which was
itself adapted from a book of children's
poems by TS Eliot Hudson who won an
Oscar in 2007 for her breakout role in
Dreamgirls will pay Grizabella the
former glamour cat who falls on hard
times and gets to sing about it in
showstopper memory it's unclear which
roles will be played by Swift's Corden
Kalin
the Daily Mail was the first to report
the casting news which was confirmed by
Variety Katz is one of the most
successful musicals in history enjoying
long runs both in London's West End and
on Broadway the possibility of a movie
version has been long bandied about okay
did you ever see cats I saw cats when I
was a kid and I fell asleep that's all I
remember
okay I don't remember I know that in the
songs memory is an iconic song what how
does it go is that the one it's so high
I don't know if I
yes yes honestly that song is a waste of
Jennifer Hudson's talents like if you're
I can sing it barely but glamour cat is
my favorite thing I've ever heard in my
life
no totally the former glass cat so is it
gonna be cartoon where they're doing the
voices or are they gonna be dressed
it says movie version that doesn't tell
us if it's live action yeah I can't
imagine it's live action that would be
beyond stupid telegenic live action or
it'll be like Beauty and the Beast where
the animated character so like Lumiere
about the plots like they were sort of
they were animated but they had very
much human human chases yeah but if it's
all cats well I guess they could do it
that way so so it would technically be
animated yeah a lot of CG a lot of seeds
that's like I don't know I think both I
think CG is short for CG like that's
like when they said that they're doing a
live-action remake of The Lion King
which they are right all right how yeah
it's all animals there's there's
literally no humans in the line right so
I really look forward to seeing you know
what modern modern animation can do but
that's really confusing and why not just
choose an easier film like I don't know
I guess they've all been done maybe
they're doing all of them they really
are now that thing matters a brother I
do this done Cinderella done no one saw
it the done I didn't see that I didn't
see it which is so crazy cause like
there's nothing there's no difference
really between Cinderella remake I'm
doing the Beast remake but Beauty and
the Beast like it was just so good smash
the it smash him at least my internet
come on - really it's so good so good I
wash it like every time I'm on a plane I
watch it it's so good except the only
problem with watching it on a plane is
like you lose a lot of the magic right
it's the same thing with greatest
showmen right you know that the be our
guest sequence like took two years to
finalize between all of the lighting and
CGI and music and Lumiere I love him
it's a masterpiece it is a masterpiece
you can't surpass the levels of magic
it's so good it's so good it's so good
so that makes me excited for cats and
honestly this is an inspired task
because first of all Taylor Swift doing
something not just putting out her out
an album like this is the perfect thing
for her because it's very like
well-respected James Corden Jennifer
Hudson it's a good cast to be in and she
is the cat lady Queen herself oh my gosh
she's dying but she got this wall I
didn't even think about that right so it
really makes a lot of sense and it's a
great next step for her I think
career-wise and if she ever wants a
chance at being an e got she's gonna
have to put herself out there in roles
like this she deserves and he got but
she does but she's not no no but like in
her life she will show service but she
definitely deserved an Oscar for her
role in Valentine's Day opposite Taylor
water oh my it's not crazy that she used
to do [ __ ] like that
that is crazy I completely forgot about
that no I know and I can use a little
Taylor on Broadway Tony style she could
be any guy she just has to like she
requires a lot of risk-taking I think do
you think John Legend is gonna be the
next C god I hope that he is but I just
get so excited about you got tree that I
hope that it's very prestigious it's so
prestigious and it's really like it's
really incredible for his [ __ ] as
those awards are getting one of each
pretty cool so I would love to see Annie
got like of our generation me too
and he deserves and also Lady Gaga
deserves oh my gosh justice for her
justice every war for that documentary
song that didn't win an Oscar until it
happens to you you don't know what it's
like until it happens to you anyways I'm
very excited about this I feel like
it'll be great
I agree great cast great casting so far
doesn't start shooting till October so
you can expect to see it in five years
72 years right it's like what if these
people aren't even saying this honey
like what I'm Taylor Swift like just
fades into the distance it's not that
that would ever happen but this goes oh
these lemons have to have so much
patience like we were just saying
descendants three just filmed rapping
but when are we actually gonna see the
movie in a year I feel like D calms roll
around pretty quickly but it might be
but if it's going interview ters true d
coms are where it's at I just sound on
the Disney I was tiny Ziva McGee
yesterday and like I have access to all
these becomes now do they have like the
old one they have some of they
a mixed bag there's some new ones a teen
beach movie underrated but there's also
smart house Johnny tsunami oh oh my gosh
I'm downloading it as soon as I get home
yeah yeah no no actually nam was never
my favorite but like I can appreciate
the artistry of it I totally agree no
never like spoke to me right but it's
cool it's cool
anyways very exciting my cats
our next story it's also in some new
casting is there a lot of people are
talked about this I don't watch Teen Mom
so I don't really I can't appreciate the
news but Bristol Palin is joining the
cast of Teen Mom og which just
inherently doesn't seem like it makes
sense to me because oh gee is the
original gangsters of Teen Mom was she
ever on Teen Mom no no but maybe because
she's an OG Teen Mom right she like it
was like life was imitating art while we
had this show Teen Mom and then like
Bristol Palin was a Teen Mom and there
was just a lot of teen moms at the time
so I do think she deserves to be grouped
in with Teen Mom yeah it's just why well
I mean why I don't know but maybe this
works late and there's a new Teen Mom in
town according to multiple outlets none
other than Bristol Palin is set to join
the cast of MTV's Teen Mom og for season
eight the casting announcement
announcement comes on the heels of
Farrah Abraham's contentious departure
from the long-running reality TV series
honestly I don't keep up with these
people before Abraham has got to go like
yeah she's scares me what's that shirt
that's like it's not making stupid
people famous like I know that they're
talking about the Kardashians but they
shouldn't beat they are taught they
should be talking about our Abraham's
they should be talking about did you see
she got in a feud with Drita from Mob
Wives wait and like you don't [ __ ] with
Drita like that's the one person you
don't start a feud with I don't watch
that much Mob Wives they've only seen a
few episodes but like I know well enough
to know that like Drita is everything
like she's a mob wife too like you don't
think y'all do it who do you think
you're I ever since mom Sarah Palin ran
for vice president of the United States
in 2008 fans have witnessed Bristol's
evolution from a teenager with a newborn
baby
aka a Teen Mom to a proud mother of
three the 27 year old gave birth to 9
year old son Tripp Johnson at the age of
17 and
students welcome two year old daughter
sailor Meyer and one-year-old daughter
at Lee Meyer in February Palin's husband
u.s. Marine veteran Dakota Meyer filed
for divorce after almost two years of
marriage okay so she was pretty much
made for a reality TV show and I'm glad
that you know now we'll get to watch
this unfold actually I won't be one oh I
was gonna say we won't be watching we
won't be what I'm not watching it
involved my favorite thing about Teen
Mom though is that they have a British
version called teen mum which is just
perfect like I'm pretty sure that's a
incredible unless I was being like -
pranked I'm pretty sure there's a
British resident called teen mum guys
which is just everything that's a show
I've watched
I have watched Teen Mom not Teen Mom and
here's the thing like I will watch the
worst television on the planet but I
draw the line at Teen Mom like me -
people go hard for it however like I
don't know but you've heard the
statistic that ever since the show
premiered like the rates of teenage
pregnancies has gotten down okay well
that's that's good that's a good thing
right you give them that they're showing
how truly treacherous it really is just
use a condom just use a condom right
words to live by
that's really crazy so I guess they're
making an impact I still won't be
watching but this seems to be everyone
is shocked by this news I've seen it
everywhere I know such funny tweets
about it really someone was like as if
America hasn't been through enough
Bristol Palin is on Teen Mom it's just
it all comes full circle even though
she's 27 minutes on Teen Mom it's like
you kind of miss your window it's fine
I'm not gonna complain three kids under
the age of 20 at the age of 27 that's
wild
that's wild she has her hands full maybe
have a watch sounds interesting
okay we'll give her a second chance okay
this next story is really sad Olympic
figure skater Dennis 10 is dead at 25
after a fatal stabbing this long news is
so shocking the figure skating world is
mourning the loss of one of their own
Olympic medalists Dennis tenten passed
away after reportedly being stabbed in
Kazakhstan he was 25 the International
Skating Union is deeply saddened by the
news from media in Kazakhstan announcing
the passing of figure skater Dennis 10
wrote on Twitter or how our heartfelt
condolences go out to Dennis's family
friends and fans across the world
International Olympic Committee
president Thomas Bach added Denis 10 was
a great athlete and great ambassador for
his sport a warm personality and a
charming man such a tragedy to lose met
such a young age according to a report
from Artie comm Dennis cut dad got into
a heated argument with two men who are
allegedly trying to steal the mayor's
office off of his car
a physical altercation followed where
the Olympic athlete was reportedly
stabbed that is so sad Denis won the
bronze medal at the 2014 Winter Olympics
in Sochi because of his win he became
the first figure skater from Kazakhstan
to medal at the Olympic Winter Games
after battling through injuries he was
able to compete in the 2018 Winter
Olympics in Pyeongchang where he
finished 27th soon after the news was
revealed several athletes express their
condolences on social media like Adam
repin Johnny Weir and some others from
the figure skating community it's really
sad it's just like a freak thing to
happen like it was random like yeah I
guess I guess that's so so sad horrible
we're thinking of his family and the
whole figure skating community that's so
young 25 so young that's my that's my
age too
yeah see we always forget the words see
I know I think that you're older than me
for something because I'm like a great
older yeah and you're great older but
I'm young for my grade I think because I
skipped a few grades smart I'm telling
people that it's not just the cutoff was
late where I'm from keep talking but I'm
also smart yeah
um and this is a really sad story but I
hope everyone can find peace and justice
is served by those vicious men yeah they
got to get through wars on cars like how
then are you huh where is Kazakh Stan
it's um
Borat yes I know it's Bora well it's
funny cuz when Bora came out I thought
they made up the country music is like
how can you just drag a country through
the mud like that but I guess you can I
guess it's it's like maybe in the
Balkans if that was the from the Russian
times right uh they quoted Artie where
is it Central Asia okay you know what
I'm sorry I know nothing about your
Asian times I didn't know what that's
what Artie was I know nothing about
geography it's in Central Asia and I
hope that justice is served for Dennis
Young's family
horrible okay this is no story so
recently the morning ptosis just really
become like a wealth of news and
knowledge and just reporting from on all
subjects yes you know big small tech
science sports music and well-rounded
well-rounded something we've never
spoken about on this show is for tonight
however NBC News is reporting that
fortnight which is free to play has
pulled in more than 1 billion dollars
report says people aren't just playing
for tonight either viewers watched about
580 million hours of game action in May
so not only are people playing for
tonight people are just watching for
tonight the way that we watch Bravo
isn't that crazy mind-blowing does your
man play for tonight No thank God
neither does mine but like I feel like
either but do adults play it or is it
just kids I think adults play - do you
guys play for tonight but adults Maya
they say no but everyone else in the
world does yeah adults play it too so
here's the info the wildly popular
online game fortnight has surpassed 1
billion dollars in revenue according to
a new report from research firm super
data it's particularly impressive number
considering the game is free-to-play and
has been out for about a year but in
that time it has turned into a
phenomenon both in terms of its
popularity as a game as well as in its
cultural impact fortnight developed by
Epic Games released in late 2017 and
makes money entirely from in-app
purchases where Pires spend real dollars
to buy in-game currency in order to
customize their avatars it's like The
Sims totally or like Kim Kardashian
Hollywood yes the game which pits a
hundred players in a fight to the death
known as a battle royale has attracted
both experienced gamers and novices to
the point where the game has become
nearly ubiquitous
with in-game victory dances turning up
in real life including at the World Cup
final oh my god what's the victory dance
anyone now
we don't know what it's called but it
looks stupid as I would imagine it's a
back limb than you land on your side
which doesn't seem totally feasible but
I guess because these are these are
video game characters they could do
whatever how they want and I guess if
you're athletic enough you can achieve
it as well super data attributes for
tonight's rapid success to the fact that
it is free and is available on a wide
variety of platforms from Nintendo
switch to Xbox one to even a mobile
version for iOS the report also notes
the added attention from celebrities and
gamers and the easy learning curve for
new players but it's not just that a lot
of new people are playing the game for
tonight has also emerged in recent month
months as one of the most-watched video
games viewers watched more than 574
million hours of for tonight on
streaming platforms which easily
outpacing other video games according to
the super Data Report the combination
for fortnight on celebrities history on
sizable audiences with with one popular
video game streamers session with rapper
Drake reading six hundred and
thirty-five thousand concurrent viewers
[ __ ] Drake please fortnight must be cool
then it's just so crazy when something
is going on in the world like so massive
and just totally taking over the carton
you just don't even know about it I know
it's like pokemons go I never played but
it was massive I never played Pokemon go
right totally except I used to love
pokemons back in the day I never got
into talks so hard with pokemons and it
was like I was your favorite
Pikachu's like way too basic maybe it
was Charmander I really don't remember
but I remember one time I like did my
chores and like I instead of an
allowance I was like can I get pokemon
cards like are you kidding me that's so
stupid
this was a sweet and innocent you had no
idea no I had no idea like how far
twenty dollars might have gone instead
of Pokemon cards and we didn't even know
how to play them because we're like four
girls we just used to like play that put
them down and pick them up just like see
what they look like no like Oh
Charmander yeah trade those were the
days guys pokemon cards simpler times
simpler times but anyways I guess the
new Pokemon is fortnight and it really
is taking over the world cuz I feel like
I've always seen
seems about fortnight me too and I mean
and I don't really like I don't relate
to them personally but I can understand
that for so what I'm gathering here he's
like a man it's like you could have your
ass in your man's face but he still
wants to play for tonight that's what
the means are yeah right like like or
he's like looking over your naked body
to play for me right those are the means
oh my gosh can you imagine no I can and
then so there's a new toasters group
called I'm in love with the toaster and
yes affectionately call themselves
Brewster's because I guess somewhat
already them are men and in there
they're already talking about for my
arms yeah what do they talk about what I
don't know they're like any fortnight
players and I guess in the comments
they're exchanging their handles and
maybe playing each other oh my gosh I
don't even know that is amazing you're
bringing so many people together yes
like mutual interests right it's
beautiful and like I always wonder
toasty community Fort Lee like people
are loving it and I wonder if I actually
took the time to sit down and play if I
would like it to but what I don't even
know what it like what is the game what
happens you it's a good like you're
trying to kill people battle Rory ah so
it's a hundred people in a pit or in a
scenario and you have to kill them and
you have weapons and you have weapons
last person standing do they want any
money they don't win money people
probably gamble on it and place bets and
then I guess if they're streaming on
Twitch you can pay people on Twitch so
like you probably can't get paid if
you're like a big fort nice winner
it's like Dungeons and Dragons exactly
or the free motto I guess it's always
something in the videos always or Super
Mario Party which why did he ever stop
playing that you guys
I love Super Mario and Mario Kart it's I
used to play that so much and it's like
now I wonder if I got a Playstation I
got Super Mario if I would like plan you
might it might be a good de-stresser you
know no tour like what did you ever play
Tony Hawk pro skater no that was a good
one really yes huh me my friends used to
play at all it mean Liz used to play it
all the time Liz Gillies yes from
dynasty from done
which is a very toasty show the toastie
show and I'm so glad that you have been
promoting it and everyone needs to watch
it he loved it so much
my god I would have forgotten to ask you
about her so Christina's best childhood
friends with Liz Gilley aka that one
from dynasty they have started filming
season 2 yeah I've been seeing on
Raphael de la Fuente insta story and
it's so funny cuz I'm so sorry he
literally acts like Sammy Jo he I saw I
haven't met him but he's like glazed
love sent me seems so cool have you met
anyone from the cast yes I went to the
set and I met I met heard the dad Blake
Blake I met the butler who was from the
OC which was a huge deal under Sanders
and he's Australian in real life he's an
Australian accent that's crazy as is
Fallon's brother Stephen Stephen all the
work accent um yeah
that's so rest'll so crazy so crystals
not coming back for season 2
I'm not sure well they she said you
should've out on Instagram and it's like
why wouldn't they just wait and have her
die or something well you know how did
the last episode at legal and doctors in
the fire right
spoiler alert sorry everyone was so
anyone right but she why would she
already say she's not coming back for
season 2 did something happen I actually
have no idea really really okay and have
you like seen any of talyn's looks for
season 2 I haven't seen any found looks
yet I'm planning to go down to the set
it's in Atlanta so I'm planning to go
probably next month so I'll report back
if I see any amazing looks and it's the
house a real house know what I serious
like yours the living room know a
situation all a set Oh everything
Fallon's office everything's a set that
makes me so sad well that was office
being a set make sense like the house
seems to have flow what's the point of
building a fake house if you could just
go to a real house it's a good question
that is deeply it's a beautiful big
staircase and even like the upstairs
make sense where one there's like two
doors to the study and like it never has
like goofs where it's like oh if you
went out that door you wouldn't end up
where you yeah they're doing really well
they do it really well but yeah like the
door the hallways when you go upstairs
like it just leads to nothing like
they're just doors oh my god I want to
does list love being on the show because
it's the best show ever yes and she I
mean even just based on the outfit she
gets to wear is it all Gucci designer
Gucci come on
maman Dolce Gabanna like everything's
amazing did she get to keep any of the
clothes I don't think she gets to keep
them now okay but maybe in the future
and like you know when celebrities like
have the greatest role like a TV show
role and they just presented and like
they don't want to talk about it like
Liz loves being Fallon right Fallon is
amazing yeah she loves it I feel like
Malin is such a good role is such a good
role and I feel like based on her
Instagram I can tell that she really
likes me because she's always posting a
person set it's perfect her she's like
wearing clothes that she would be
wearing anyway right and she's just like
always so bad
always so glam like just living the best
life whatever she has she said anything
that Nicollette Sheridan no she said
like great to work with iconic obviously
and yeah did she watch the old dynasty
so she's a huge fan of Joan Collins so
and she actually got to meet her which
was awesome for her and I think once she
got the role or was auditioning for the
role she went back and watched all of
them just like to do research and it was
just like it's it's amazing like it's an
iconic a really and I really really hope
like toasters we need to be toast or
strong on this one like we need the show
to go on for a very long time because
it's like the closest thing we're gonna
get to like Gossip Girl 2.0 exactly and
maybe we can get with all the toast at
some point when she say something or you
just cross if we have to go down to
Atlanta we can make it happen also we'll
be there for the Superbowl so maybe we
can do like oh oh my god go to the Super
Bowl you should go we got let you know
during the Super Bowl that's a good idea
great and we could stay at the
Carrington's yes the fake house don't
remind me um it's speaking of fake movie
set houses wow you guys I couldn't have
asked for a better segue Thank You Cyn
the Brady Bunch house hits the market
for nearly one point nine million
dollars here's the story of a lovely
family home which just hit the market
for 1.88 five million dollars which I
don't know seems
during its like a one floor hasn't been
updated since the 70s ranch-style like
you would have to take like that's a
that's a fixer-upper totally I've
actually seen it like I've driven past
but where is it it's an L it's in LA
somewhere so I went and drove past once
just to see it and yeah it's definitely
fixed wow it looks like it's stuck in
the 70 this photo though it looks really
nice the landscaping is nice the
landscaping is nice and definitely like
on real estate calm like they they put
up some nice photos like that sunset mmm
pretty and it's like they lit the house
inside so it looks nicer on the outside
I see your tricks remember the backyard
moored leaves to do like potato sack
races yes
honestly I'm I'm excited for whoever
buys this house I do hope it is a true
fan though and that doesn't like tear it
down because it's a little piece of
history and honestly I'd rather live in
this house in the full house house same
when I read that it's considered the
second most famous house in the country
just after the White House what that's
what it's considered more than full
house more than full house it's number
two that's I don't know what number full
house is though that I would like to
find out must be three oh my goodness
so the Brady Bunch house a traditional
style residence near the Colfax Meadows
neighborhood was used for outdoor
representations of the beloved
television family's abode honestly I
feel like at this point that
kardashian-jenner house could be number
three even the house and then their old
ranch-style house we never force yeah
totally
that included the show's opening and
closing scenes as well as numerous
interludes to denote the time of day
interior scenes for the Brady Bunch were
filmed in studio okay so things haven't
changed that much because I was about to
say like if they were filming in a house
back in the day like why can't they film
dynasty and him in a mansion but we're
gonna have to find out I'm gonna move on
from it violet and George McCallister
bought the two bedroom three bedroom
house in 1973 for sixty one thousand
dollars records show the series ran from
September 1969 to March 1974 before
moving into reruns in syndication
Ernie Carswell a Douglas Elliman agent
who was listing the property said the
split-level house has been updated and
upgraded but retains almost the exact
interior decor from that era though the
layout does not resemble the TV show
home right it's like if you're buying a
TV home you want that interior of course
otherwise what's the point yes I mean
Christ like what more than what it's
worth just because it's a thing
house totally so that's what you want it
to look like but then it's also like
people are gonna be driving by all the
time that kind of is the factor and the
full House house they just shut down the
street to commercial vehicles so like
buses tour buses can't go by it anymore
because all the neighbors complain but
isn't there a park across the street
yeah so can't everyone just go to the
park you just can't take like a tour bus
like a you know like the hop-on hop-off
of San Francisco and go by the house
house that's crazy I see so many
pictures of people like jumping in front
of it and it's like Dan that's annoying
who lives there I wonder someone it has
to be someone thirsty like you can't
live there if you're not 30 yeah you you
go into it knowing that there's gonna be
a lot of people it's the same thing with
Carrie Bradshaw's brownstone I think
about that all the time too true every
one of those houses I would just like
leave a sign on the door says like
follow me on instagram my hair bums at
the morning toast at pub listen a job at
girls no job at tiffany thornton at boys
no job at Olivieri at Marc Lasry at
Bondi by some inch well we have a lot of
family handles and that's not even all
of them hungry hungry hungry hungry is a
good one I'm hungry I'm not hungover I
haven't tried for a few days I'm waiting
till Sunday that's good I always say I'm
not gonna drink during the week but then
I get home from work and I'm like one
glass
and it really won't doctor says yeah
good for the heart a rock wall fireplace
in wood paneled walls are among classic
details found in the living room which
features a built-in bar ooh okay now
we're talking floral wallpaper and when
no coverings are another vintage touch
the homes music hall intercom and whole
house radio also remain this is a
postcard of exactly what Holmes looked
like in the 1970s I mean that's really
sweet if you like our a 1970s like
fetishes which I feel there definitely
are there definitely are and it's there
are worse things to be
it was a good time do you ever watch Mad
Men yes of course so you know the
apartment that they move into that like
yes and that Draper I love it like
that's the interior of the Brady Bunch
house yeah definitely similar to that so
and I wonder no that's definitely is
that and she took all the furniture
definitely sorry anyway speaking of TV
shows we need to recap southern charm
yes last night was part one of the
reunion and I have so many thoughts I I
don't even think I'm gonna remember
so first of all this episode should have
been called true justice for Kathryn
even though all season has been leading
up to this like oh my god I wanted to
cry when Cameron was crying and I'm
really so glad that Cameron recognized
how mean she was to Kathryn just based
on what Thomas had said about her and
like really all came full circle and I
personally forgive Cameron like I love
her so much as a person but just when it
came to Kathryn I thought she was just
like not the nicest mmm and on the wrong
side of history a little bit because
I've been standing Kathryn since day one
and I always understood where she was
coming from and I feel like I'm the only
person on the planet who can say that
maybe my head's me probably I just
identified with her and almost wish we
were doing the show five years ago
because I would have liked the proof
that was like I was always team Kathryn
right just like how now I'll have the
proof that I was always team Bethany
when I turns out that I'm right it's
another team Kentucky you're on you're
on the wrong side of your you are and I
just the reason why I'm not getting
scrappy about fighting about it is
because I'm just sitting back and
waiting for like justice like for the
trips to fall where they may
and for the right for the winner to be
announced and but the one thing is like
Bethany keeps saying that Carroll is
going through a midlife crisis but I
feel like Bethany is the one going
through a midlife crisis I was just
going through crisis after crisis yeah
she's in a permanent crisis I think she
is going through a midlife crisis the
way that she's acting and behaving like
she thinks she is she's acting like 20
or I feel like she's always active like
she's always at know she there's a
difference to the way she's acting she
always acted like young and hip and
downtown and she's acted cool cuz she is
cool but now she's just acting like the
way I'm like a middle schooler acts on
their phone like taking selfies with
Tinsley and like traveling
whereas I felt like before cavil was
traveling and being cool she wasn't like
so concerned with like taking selfies
and like posting about it I don't know I
just feel like she was like a cool girl
like didn't have to try and now it feels
like she's really trying okay and the
side commentary like the things that
she's saying like in Bethany side Karen
Terry she like makes me laugh so hard
and I choose Bethany it's really funny
and Carol's not and Carol's just like
cringe-worthy and I'm just
beside with the cringe I just have never
been team Bethenny me neither of them
that's why I feel even stronger that
Bethenny is right because I shouldn't be
having this strong of a reaction but
don't you feel like she's just like
she's just rude I feel she's just
miserable and she takes it out on other
people I don't feel like she's miserable
as like a human being I feel like
circumstances have forced her like she's
very stressed out and so I know
she's and she's had to go through a lot
when they're like out to dinner I'd like
someone who's a misery to be around it's
like they can't smile they can't laugh
like just please leave I don't feel that
way with her I feel like yes she has a
lot going on in the back of her mind but
when she's like drinking or having fun
with Sonja like they're truly having a
good time yeah
and so I'm talking someone like
miserable is so like mean so when when
Carole saying that to her like you're
just miserable to be around like don't
use like that applies to some people
it's not applying to a situation right
now she's a lot on her plate it's
definitely like clouding her on this
trip but I don't think she's miserable
to be around I think she's looking to
have a good time and it's like
everywhere she goes she's being attacked
whether it's from her husband from the
court from Carol from Dorinda who like
what burrito Perico turn denieth
together together this season and I love
Dorinda but she's I don't totally agree
with her this season at all yeah she
just keeps stepping in it and it's like
Bethenny was such a good friend to you
she could have brought anyone to Puerto
Rico you're probably thinking like she's
not talking to Carol she chose you and
like you turn on her over a nutcracker
what she thanked you for Nutcracker
The Nutcracker yeah The Nutcracker was
the craziest thing I've seen and whose
side were you on there The Nutcracker
I'm on Bethany side okay good because
she did thank her and she was so happy
and she what come what more of a
reaction I didn't want I know yeah that
was crazy and the marathon texts the
marathon texts need me to refresh my
memory what did she text her she texted
her like Congrats like a couple
different times in like it wasn't like a
big enough reaction for Carol who also
didn't answer the texts carol was like
also a little bit annoying about the
marathon like she made a little she did
make too big a deal out of it like
people from the marathon all the time
it's over it is an amazing feat it is
and honestly when I watch her run them
all the stuff leading up to the marathon
was annoying but when she finished the
marathon I was like wow that really is a
big deal especially to do like so late
in life I mean she never worked out
before right so like I think that's an
accomplishment but everything else like
you don't run the marathon so everyone
can say congrats on running the marathon
like you've really run it for ourselves
so right if that's what you're looking
for is validation from Bethany keep
looking anyway let's go yes I'm so happy
to see Cameron just like breakdown
understand where Katherine's coming from
and to close the book on that because
like it's a long time coming
I'm just annoyed because Thomas isn't
there like this should be happening in
front of Tom it's like he did all of
this to Katherine he's gonna get off
scot-free
especially because Katherine's not gonna
talk [ __ ] about him cuz she's gonna play
by the rules she wants her custody she
wants her child support like she can't
even say anything so know what Thomas is
never gonna have his day in Bravo Court
which is annoying I think he might how I
mean well just think judging by the
lawsuit center he's gonna say in court
first a regular court but like I grew up
in Bravo Court like no he needs to be
held accountable for all the terrible
things that he did to Katherine and the
situations that he's put her in like
yeah her having to take a drug test
still whenever he decides even though
he's under criminal investigation for
raping women like that's crazy maybe
just like it let it go for a second you
know she's not doing drugs made me
decide to trust her because you're the
most untrustworthy man on the place
right face of the earth yeah no that's
that's crazy it's a man's world so it is
but as Katherine said like the good ol
boy system is dying I look forward to
being it dead buried in the ground
don't worry ah someone's calling me you
can scram don't you know I do a morning
show next up I want to talk about Naomi
and Craig because I have never laughed
harder from a TV show from a Bravo show
then what do you mean was like she was
talking about her nose job and Craig was
like you know it just made me so sad
like I think you're so beautiful and
when you look in the mirror like you
didn't see that same beauty and she was
like and which was kind of a dig to say
cuz it's like Oh Craig thought you were
so beautiful and you thought you were
ugly like you have no self-worth like he
was trying to like be on his soapbox a
little bit and then when she was like I
mean
I didn't see Quasimodo in the mirror I
just didn't like my nose and it's like
thank you like it doesn't have to be
that deep like that do you face Carol I
would say I don't know what we're 20
years old we can say that yeah 25 we're
in our 24 24 24 yeah um I was laughing
so hard because like anyone else would
have been like he would have won that
argument just by being like I loved you
the way you were and clearly you didn't
love yourself and then that speaks like
a larger issue made me like she didn't
love herself enough to be with him cuz
I've you have to love yourself before
you come on someone Alice like no [ __ ]
no I did not see cause Emoto it's just
my nose I was laughing for her I fell
asleep before that part I literally had
to pause like I was watching was AK he's
never seen me laugh so hard from a TV
show and it was just so fun I wasn't
expecting not like oh my god it was
amazing so anyways Craig and Amy are
legitimately never getting back together
never ever but I'm okay I've made peace
with it and you know like I think you
like you enjoyed them as a couple I
enjoy them as a couple I enjoy them both
as individuals like on TV and in real
life we've like hung out with them
multiple times and I really like them
both so much like they're both great
people and so when they first broke up
honestly I was kind of waiting for them
to get back together and even watching
the show this season like there were a
few times there they almost did and I
was hoping that they might be hopeless
romantic
but you know what they're both great
people and they'll find other great
people and that doesn't mean that they
have to be together and Craig was being
very frustrating during the reunion on
the one hand being like Naomi tell me
one lie I ever said to you and then on
the other hand being like I can't help
myself or mine and then he's like you
can't even say a lie I did 20 minutes
later I just lied about everything
because I can he used to get a story
straight he needs to just be like held
accountable and he really is the
definition of talking in circles he
reminds me of like someone in the
workplace who liked is a presentation
and like they're talking so much that
you think they're saying something but
if you're actually listening yeah
they're not saying anything but no one's
really listening so they get away with
it it sounds like they are really
prepared right like he's the type of kid
in class who like didn't do the reading
but it's gonna raise his hand you know
it's like totally how brave are you and
like no one like no one else did the
reading so no one that knows that you're
not saying anything right except for the
professor who's not an [ __ ] enough to
call you out story of my life
anyways I just felt like the reunion I
almost wanted to like tie it up in a bow
and put it away after last night's
episode because it was everything we
needed and like now as she's coming out
and like so did she come out at the end
or no no they just intermittent leave
right that was her yeah doing her hair
sin fell asleep during the I fell asleep
wait but do you know what's so funny is
that we reported this on page six com
that she had like a 5 p.m. call time and
she showed up at 8 a.m. we did the
reunion taping that's all I could make
sense me when I was lost last night
watching you like her just like messing
with her hair and like the whole time
just showing like her
obsessing over because she had a lot of
time oh my goodness and it's so crazy
you know what really spoke to me when
she got out of the car and she's being
so polite to the driver so open the car
thank you thank you and it's like that
is the woman who walked onto the set of
the morning toast that we met and that's
why we were so kind to her and listened
hurt her out it was before Hilton had
happened so we were like you know maybe
this woman like really is a kind person
missing wants to make it work with
Katherine we had no clue what was coming
in the season we knew that she called
Katherine an egg donor but you know
people have bad days so it's fine so
like you're willing to look past it so
that like when she was being so nice to
everyone the makeup artist like be like
oh you know I have a little temper so I
just you know need to keep it sweet like
that's who we met on the toast and
that's how we were so duped into do
having a rational conversation with her
anyways so what did she say when she was
on the toast and I think I missed setup
oh my god
so she was just saying that she like
just really wants to like be a co-parent
to Katherine like everything that you
would think a normal person would say
you know about her relationship with
Thomas how she got on the show how she
met Thomas her life as a nurse why she
hadn't been practice or young practicing
nursery in Charleston everything was
just like very logical clear-cut and I
really and Thomas came here with her oh
really huh right there met him took
pictures with them he was sitting right
there this was before the allegation of
course so it seemed they seemed like a
really like sweet couple he was like
supporting her on her first big
interview with like an at international
news agency very prestigious and they
were like really sweet normal and wow
wow times have changed way where we
duped so anyways when she got out of the
car
they spoke to me and I was like oh I
understand how we thought the things
that we thought right before we saw the
show so next week looks very nasty and
what bothers me is it seems as though
from talking to like some of the cast
members and you know even what Bravo has
head is like by the end of her whole
tirade next week like I think people
will start to feel bad for her cuz she
seems a little bit like brainwashed yeah
it's very very thin she's almost like a
prisoner but that will just let her off
the hook you know
saying that I feel like her and Thomas
are both gonna get off the hook on this
one by saying she's like he's crazy he's
made her crazy he doesn't have to show
up to be held accountable for his
actions and it's kind of annoying
because like he deserves to experience
one morsel of what Kathryn has gone
through on reunions ya know so you don't
think she's gonna take accountability at
all no I think she's gonna continue to
be an [ __ ] by the end they're just
gonna feel like she's brainwashed even
though like she pursued him she moved to
Charleston like she is the one that
letting go of him
right you know but they're gonna be oh
he has he has her under his thumb but
like I don't know if it's it fits like
that cuz like it seems like she's really
she's like I have all this [ __ ] on you
like I'm not going anywhere
so thanks TBD will see I truly feel like
right now southern charm is the best
show on TV I need to catch up I'm not I
don't know fully caught up i-i've seen
it here and there especially this season
I've caught more than I have past
seasons but I need to start from the
beginning and go through the whole
experience because so many people tell
me it's the best show on Bravo it's the
best reality show on TV so I need to I
always like I wanna watch it from the
beginning too because it's like every
crazy thing that happened happened
because they are doing this show like
right Thomas and Kathryn never would
have met if not for the show so like
saying everything is there for you to
watch so it really I feel like with a
lot of like Housewives it's like all
this stuff happened off camera or like
Camille like Kyle said to Camille like
oh they're filming without you
off-camera we don't know what the hell
happened we just all inferring right
here it's all there for us to see and
watch her through the lens of Kathryn is
not that bad and I think you'll be
surprised from what I've heard from what
I know about her I feel for her like I
don't
think of her as any sort of villain or
anything
totally like the world did but not this
girl not me and even Cameron was like
Cameron was talking about how when she
first gave birth like she really
struggled yeah right okay I thought it
was she's just like the most open brave
like honest person on Instagram and I
just I sir I really really appreciate it
and I'm sure so many people watching
just completely related to her and
didn't realize that that was something
that like most women feel right
especially when she said like how when
she held her baby shouldn't feel an
immediate connection I'm sure people
feel that way and no one is brave enough
to say that out loud right and she said
it but it's like she has such a track
record of being an open book and like
honest and funny and real that would be
like when she says something it's like
you don't judge her you're just like wow
thank you for sharing so when she said
she was going through all of that and
she can't imagine Kathryn going through
that without a support system like
without a man by her side like right and
with the whole world against her I was
just like thank you I know anyways I was
very proud of her I was a very beautiful
moment I almost cried I feel like if I
had had kids I would have definitely
cried yeah you know but like having said
until you're a mother you don't
understand so maybe I don't even
understand I have one question for you
because he forgot page six and we were
talking about this on the show the other
day this Kelly Cutrone story where she
threatened the police because um she
called a man like exposed to himself in
front of her huh and she like got on the
phone and they wouldn't pick up for two
hours and she was like I had 135,000
Instagram followers I'm a big New York
Times bestselling author like I'm gonna
call page six and report it did Kelly
Cutrone ever call page six I can't speak
to that
because if she did she wouldn't have
called me so who knows but if she was
threatening it maybe I don't know
and like Kelly Cutrone is someone who I
haven't thought about in so long no I
feel like there was another story with
her recently something she accused oh
she accused somebody of sexual
harassment maybe well Russell Simmons
yeah I think so so that was the last
time I thought about her and before then
I hadn't thought about her since Lauren
Conrad was worth interning for right so
I'm not sure okay definitely didn't call
me or if she did no one picked up and
therefore she should stop yelling at and
I
one operators that's funny that she said
that yeah it was like it was so crazy
anyways spin thank you for joining us
thank you for having me it was so fun it
was so fun have a great time at Taylor
Swift tonight where can everyone follow
you everyone can follow me at Kristen
McNamara on Instagram I just saw
verified last week I cleaner I saw the
other day they got terrified and I was
like how long does that been there for
literally last week so now I'm just as
prestigious as you oh my gosh you'll see
it means everything um thank you guys
for watching we will see you on Monday
have a wonderful wonderful weekend I am
your always loyal host Jackie O problems
feel free to follow me and Tiffany
Thornton I'm Claudia because she's not
here to tell you that herself and CEO
because he post premium content was so
premium so in love with you okay I need
to go have enough peace me just day uh
yeah have a great weekend everyone I
will see you on Monday after the Taylor
Swift concert changes my life and if it
doesn't it will I'll be so a
disappointed it's going to
you